let's start today with the latest on the
pandemic in the united states and around
the world then i want to look at the
question do any religions actually
prohibit vaccination for all of the talk
about
i have a religious exemption from being
vaccinated
what religions ban being vaccinated if
any we're going to look at that in a
moment now
last week i came to you and i said covet
cases are down 53 percent in the u.s
from their delta peak deaths are down 33
in the u.s from their delta peak that
was last week and we said
what will the next week look like well
it's now next week relative to last week
and the numbers are once again better
let's look at those numbers and see just
how much better the u.s average daily
covid cases are now down 59 percent from
their delta wave peak of 167 000 a day
the u.s now seeing 68 000 cases per day
yes it's a crazy number
but it's the lowest it's been since late
july
and for now
it's pointing down rather than pointing
up and that's a good thing
in terms of daily us deaths the delta
wave peak was all the way back up to
just a hair under 2 000 deaths a day
that is now down to about
1275 deaths a day
of a tragic number but a decline of 35
percent so both cases and deaths
declining in the last week cases
declining more than deaths on a
percentage basis okay
what's the global context what's
happening globally well globally cases
are actually going back up
this is being led by some specific
countries which i'll tell you about in a
moment but globally cases have gone up
it's not a big change
but cases globally we're down to about
403 000 a day they're now back up to 416
000 a day it's a small change but it
could be meaningful it could mean one of
two things number one
we could be seeing the start of another
wave with winter coming to the northern
hemisphere that's that's a possibility
it could just be a blip
we don't know yet but this is being led
by some countries with major increases
in cases last week i'll give you some
examples the czech republic has gone
from like they were almost at zero they
had 150 cases a day
they're at 3 000 a day 150 to 3 000 a
day that's a huge spike in the czech
republic and when i tell you the other
countries where we're seeing increases
you'll start to notice a regional trend
hungary poland slovenia are seeing big
spikes hungary went from 70 cases a day
to 2000. poland went from 150 cases a
day to 5 000. slovenia went from 60
cases a day all the way up to about
1750.
just those few countries already that's
a major increase and you look at the
others slovakia croatia ukraine
all seeing significant increases in
cases so it could be that area also big
concerns in the united kingdom at one
point last week the united kingdom had
the highest case rate i believe in the
world now stabilizing at a very bad
number of 45 000 cases a day in the uk
that's all bad
so the question is is that coming to the
uk
coming to the u.s rather we saw with
delta that it started in europe and then
we were just lagging behind i think it
was like six to eight weeks or something
like that so is what's happening in some
of these european countries now going to
be here in six or eight weeks we just
don't know yet you can find opinions
saying yes you can find opinions saying
no
one view is we are going to see a
decline and we are going to get to sort
of like endemic levels where you get
yourself vaccinated
if you do or participate in indoor
events with a bunch of people maybe
everybody gets tested i've been to a
couple events including a birthday party
where that was the protocol
that's one of you we're getting down to
that endemic level
the other view is this is about to
explode as we head into winter in the
united states what do we know about the
u.s right now we know that vaccination
is basically flat at a very low level
we're doing about eight hundred thousand
vaccinations per day with reports
indicating that there are more third
doses in those 800k than first doses
that's very very bad
we know that we are believed to be very
close to vaccine approval for 5 to
eleven year olds and fda panel
recommending that approval yesterday and
now we're just waiting for broader
approval it could be that we start
vaccinating five to eleven year olds as
soon as next friday um that's uh that
that's something we're following
we know that schools where you are not
required to wear a mask are seeing
significantly higher covered case rates
than those where you are so masks
continue to be relevant for those
unvaccinated kids
also new
the cdc is now saying that some
immunocompromised people
uh can and should
get a fourth coveted shot that is
not something that was previously
discussed in any great detail and now
the cdc is saying yeah it's not just a
third dose for some immunocompromised
people
uh we should be looking and even
starting to do fourth doses so we're
going to follow all of this case is down
here uh but increasing globally and the
question is are we headed for a very
dark winter or are we headed for a not
so bad winter with things being
essentially everything open
um some places with vaccine requirements
some places vaccine or testing
requirements
etc as we've been seeing so we will
continue to follow it we'll see where we
are
by next week we could either be
at 60 percent down from the delta peak
or we could start to see a turnaround
which would not be very good